what's up BAM Sampson here I was playing
some Borderlands pre-sequel and I ran
across this crazy purple monolith and
now I'm going to show you how to get
there so start off in Triton flats head
down and up into the right the second
you get into Stantons liver there's a
jump pad right here on the right side
after sniping a couple dudes down below
down here just make a right-hand turn
grab a couple weapons over here in this
crate I got a couple greens and then
turn around the do down here swag man
he's like a level 12 guy you can take
him at level 8 so if you find yourself
under level 2 take him out go ahead and
stay on mission and then by the end of
the mission you should have the right
level to do it I was playing here as
well hound just threw out your drones
hit him a couple times in the head you
should be good to go also be careful
there's some relatively high level bugs
in this cave and if swagman and the bugs
come at you at the same time it can be a
problem so after you take down swag man
go ahead and check out what he's got I
picked up at level 11 laser rifle from
him I wasn't able to use it for another
couple levels but it's worth holding
onto in your inventory so once you've
done that I head straight across cave go
through this portal in the upper back
wall and head straight down they got a
plenty of oxygen for you to pick up
along the way here so don't worry about
your oz kit running out once you get
down here there's going to be a couple
ways of guys for you to fight so just go
ahead and burn through them but anyway
there it is there's the crazy purple
monolith get ready for a mild acid trip
when you jump through that thing go
ahead and take out some armored outlaws
and then head on down once you to the
base of the monolith it'll trigger
another wave of armored outlaws but by
now you should be a pro and I guess just
if you're Wilhelm just unleash
Wolfenstein take them out there's a loot
crate down here it's got some okay gear
although
randoms game picked up a nice oz kit and
then when you're ready go ahead and jump
on into the monolith and you get this
crazy purple acid trip
the cool thing is this area that I got
dropped in tubes all 2001 Space Odyssey
has a breathable atmosphere so my
question would be in my back on Pandora
because the moon does not have a
breathable atmosphere I'm also curious
as I play deeper into Borderlands
pre-sequel whether I'll run into more of
these things if there's a running
storyline but for now just this one
glowing purple monolith there's really
nothing in this area so I jumped back in
went into freaky horror movie room with
a clock I have no idea where this is got
some nice portraitures of Marcus gun
bringer on the wall and a loot chest
so again just got a couple greens
nothing I really needed I'm wondering if
you come back to this area later in the
game if there won't be some high-level
loot drops and I'm a space baby back
through the portal again and it locks
you out once you get back to Higgins
gully you can explore around again but
you cannot go back into the monolith so
that's where the crazy purple monolith
in Borderlands pre-sequel is if you find
any more of these let us know and we'll
go check them out thanks for watching
[Music]